in this video we're gonna get a little
bit of practice multiplying and dividing
decimals by ten hundred and a thousand
so let's just start with a little bit of
a warm-up if I were to say what is two
point zero five times ten pause this
video and see if you can figure that out
well in previous videos result we've
already said that when you multiply by
ten you shift each of the digits one
place to the left and so this is going
to be equal to instead of two ones we're
not going to have two tens so two in the
tens place and then instead of zero
tenths we're now going to have zero ones
and instead of five hundredths we're now
going to have five tenths so this is
equal to twenty point five now what if
we were to go the other way around what
if we were to say two point zero five
divided by 10 pause the video and see if
you can figure that out
well here all of our digits are going to
shift one place to the right because
we're dividing by ten we could also view
that as multiplying by one tenth and so
our two ones are going to become two
tenths so this is going to be zero point
so we're gonna have two tenths now our
zero tenths are going to be zero
hundredths and then our five hundredths
are going to be five thousandths and
we've covered that in other videos but
now let's do this with say a hundred or
a thousand so if I were to ask you what
is 57 divided by 1,000 pause this video
and see if you can work that out all
right now let's do this together so when
you divide by a thousand that's the same
thing as dividing by 10 three times or
it's the same thing as multiplying by
1/10 three times or you could just say
hey that means I'm going to shift each
of these digits three places to the
right and so let me create some places
here so there's tens ones tens hundreds
thousands and so
five was in the tens place it's five
tens so it was here but we're going to
shift three places to the right one two
three
so our five will go there so what was
five tens is now five hundredths and
then our seven is similarly going to it
was in the ones place but we're going to
shift three places to the right one two
three and there you have it what was
just 57 is now fifty-seven thousandths
and to make that very clear I'll put a
zero in the tenths place and a zero in
the one place in the ones place and that
makes sense so it's another example
let's say someone walks up to you on the
street and says I started with one 0.03
two and I multiplied it by something and
I was able to get one hundred and three
point - what did they multiply by to get
one hundred and three point to pause
this video and try to work it out well
to understand this we just have to think
well how much did the each digit get
shifted by so what was in the ones place
got shifted not just to the tens place
but it got shifted to the hundreds place
so it got shifted two places to the left
the zero similarly got shifted two
places to the left from the tenths to
the tens and if you look at it every
digit got shifted two places to the left
and so we must have multiplied by 10
twice so you could say times 10 times 10
or you could just rewrite this as times
100
let's just do one more example for kicks
let's say that someone were to say what
is 0.01 5 times 100 pause this video and
see if you can figure that out
all right well like we've done before
we're just going to shift every digit
two places to the left so the one which
is in the hundredths place is going to
end up in
one's place and then the five which is
in the thousands place is going to end
up in the tenths place so this is going
to be equal to one point five and we're
done